Superhero movies are jam packed with action,
explosions, fight sequences and characters
you can’t take your eyes off of, so it is
understandable when you miss a hidden reference
in a movie.
Some times a hidden Easter egg isn’t found
out for months after the films release, which
make them even more exciting.
Today we are going to look at some that you’ve
probably never seen but all of them you should
know about if you are a true superhero movie
fan.
As you watch don’t forget to subscribe to
Screen Rant and join our notification squad
so you can like and comment on all our great
videos.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Easter
Eggs Hidden in Superhero Movies You Need to
See.
Guardians of the Galaxy
The cosmic entities created the infinity stones,
which are the driving force behind the MCU
films.
Thanos needs these stones to complete his
Infinity Gauntlet and complete his plans.
Guardians of the Galaxy references the four
cosmic beings twice in their first film, once
when Starlord steals the orb and then again
during the Collector’s scene when they show
the six stones.
These characters are very important to the
MCU and maybe they have something to do with
the plot of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2.
We’ll have to wait and see.
X-Men: Apocalypse
X-Men: Apocalypse is the conclusion of the
"First Class" trilogy, but it won’t be the
last X-Men movie obviously.
In the post credits scene a vial of Wolverine’s
blood is picked up and placed in a suitcase
labeled, "ESSEX CORP." True X-Men fans know
this briefcase belongs to Nathaniel Essex,
also known as Mister Sinister.
He’s one of X-Men’s most dangerous enemies
and that’s why so many of us were hoping
to see him in Logan.
Even though we didn’t the director and studio
assures us Mister Sinister is coming in a
future film.
The Avengers
In the Thor number 274 comic cook released
in 1978 we get introduced to Odin’s ravens,
Hugin and Munin and Disney’s MCU introduced
them in 2011’s Thor.
These characters are important because Ordin
sends them out to his Nine Realms each day
to learn what is happening.
In The Avengers Thor takes Loki from the S.H.I.E.L.D.
quinjet and they have a heated conversation
on top of a mountain.
Odin must have been looking after his two
boys because Hugin and Munin fly right by
them.
Do you know the director’s name of the first
Thor movie?
Was it James Gunn, Peter Quill or Kenneth
Branagh.
Stick around until the end for the answer.
The Dark Knight
Heath Ledger may be the fan favorite character
of the Joker but he was definitely not the
first actor to dawn the infamous white makeup.
Cesar Romero first portrayed the Clown Prince
in the original 1966 series with Adam West
as Batman and Eartha Kitt as Catwoman.
Christopher Nolan saluted Romero with the
first scenes that the Joker appears, as the
Joker robs a bank look at the mask.
It’s a reference to the clown mask that
Romero wore in his first episode as the Joker
in "The Joker is Wild" from the Batman television
series.
Deadpool
When Deadpool causes accidents and numerous
deaths to get his hands on Ajax take a look
at the road signs.
One says, “Parker Boulevard,” which is
a direct reference to Peter Parker and when
Deadpool pops his head over the car crash
another sign reads, “Nicieza Street.”
That’s to reference Deadpool’s co-creater
Fabian Nicieza, despite’s Deadpools comedic
mockery or superhero films you can tell the
filmmakers really respect this genre and we
love them for that.
Here’s a question for you, True or False:
Wade Wilson’s childhood hero was Captain
America.
We’ll give you the answer at the end of
our video.
Captain America: Civil War
When part of the Avengers team tries to stop
Brock Rumlow from stealing a biological weapon,
the Falcoln releases a drone.
The drones name is Redwing, that’s a reference
to Falcon’s comic book character whose sidekick
was an actual bird with the name Redwing.
Check out the actor playing Brock Rumlow,
his name is Damon Poitier and he actually
showed up in another Marvel film.
He played Thanos in The Avengers post credits
scene.
Suicide Squad
The scene where the Joker lays down surrounded
by knifes and other weapons is a reference
the Pink Floyd’s the wall.
The director David Ayer even confirmed this
reference and you can easily see the similarities.
Take a look at this shot a little closer.
See the baby clothes up on the top right of
the shot?
That is a connection to Harley’s dream that
shows up later in the film.
We wonder how many other references the film
makes in all those deleted scenes.
The Dark Night Rises
During the football game where Bane makes
his speech after complimenting a boys voice
we get a glimpse of a missing character in
the Christopher Nolan’s trilogy, Robin.
Stop right there, the character of Blake played
by Joseph Gordon-Levitt doesn’t count as
a Robin character just yet, hopefully in a
spin-off he does though.
During the football game you can see fans
holding up a sign for the Gotham City Rogues
football team but take a closer look at that
“R”.
The “R” is a homage to the Robin logo
that we have seen in the past.
Do you know how many live-action Batman incarnations
there has been?
Five, Eight or Ten, the answer is coming up
shortly.
Batman V Superman: Dawn of Justice
Whether you are team Batman or team Superman
you will get a kick out of this Easter egg
dropped in by writers Chris Terrio and David
S. Goyer.
When police are sitting in their car, checkout
what the woman says over the intercom to the
squad car.
She said, “Delta Charlie Twenty-Seven”,
which stands for DC 27 a reference to detective
comics number 27.
That’s the comic that first introduced the
world to Batman.
She also goes on to give an address.
1939 stands for the year Batman debuted in
comic book number 27.
Deadpool 2
Deadpool 2 is a highly anticipated sequel
to the first film released in 2016, many fans
were hoping for a Wolverine and Deadpool cross
over film but the chances are slim.
Fingers crossed it does happen.
In the first film, the Merc with a Mouth makes
an R-rated joke about Wolverine and how he
helped him get his own film but in the trailer
for Deadpool 2 we see another Wolverine reference.
When he runs into a phone booth, a la Superman
take a look at the movie playing in the background.
It’s Logan and later on we see Logan’s
poster but also take a look at the name on
the phone booth from earlier.
The name is Nathan Summers, who you might
know as Cable.
There you have it ten Easter Eggs Hidden in
Superhero Movies You Need to See.
Here are the answers to our trivia questions:
The director of Thor was Kenneth Branagh.
The answer is true, Wade Wilson’s childhood
hero was Captain America.
And there has been eight different live-action
Batmen including Ben Affleck.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.